[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Louis bourge bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes députés modem
des Hauts-de-Seine et vous présidez la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'Assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice lecerdon le
groupe Evra bonjour Fabrice
bonjour Jean-Luc bourlange vous revenez
tout juste du crâne que vous étiez
pendant plusieurs jours vous êtes rendu
notamment avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a une brune
Pivet qu'est-ce que vous retenez de ce
voyage écoutez nous retenons d'avoir
cette toujours très impressionnant c'est
c'est très dépaysant d'aller en Ukraine
parce que ces moyens de transport assez
particulier cette longue nuit en train
et on arrive dans un pays qui est
totalement en guerre totalement mobilisé
très accueillant très très accueillant à
ceux de ses amis comme nous qui et ils
ont venus leur apporter la solidarité
et nous avons donc rencontré
ça nous allait une partie de la
délégation est allée sur les sur les
lieux de des atrocités et nous avons
tous rencontré
les très hauts les plus hauts
responsables à commencer par le
président celanski et il rencontre avec
le président de ski c'est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant parce que c'est un
c'est un personnage qui il est plus
fascinant encore en relation directe à
la télévision parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui s'adresse à vous qui vous parle qui
vous avez vous avez immédiatement un
rapport avec lui il est plein de charme
plein d'intelligence d'une très grande
vivacité d'une très grande mobilité et
ceux qui caractérisent fondamentalement
sa démarche c'est une absolue
détermination et les messages que nous
avons reçus étaient des messages
ultra déterminés je ne négocierai pas
avec Poutine si je suis prêt à négocier
avec les Russes mais il faut qu'il
change le gouvernement donc vous
comprenez ce message il a raison de dire
ça pour vous je ne sais pas si la raison
en tout cas il est évident que Poutine
les discours et les actions de routine
depuis plusieurs mois on discrédité
comme interlocuteur en même temps si on
attend un changement hypothétique sur
lequel personne n'a prises en Russie ça
veut dire qu'on est réussira pas avant
très longtemps mais en même temps on ne
voit pas sur quoi négocier parce que
Poutine a organisé
des référendum dans des conditions mais
non seulement illégales mais totalement
aberrante dans les oblastes qu'il a
rattachée à la Fédération de Russie les
résultats ne signifie rien il a
construit sur ce référendum une espèce
cérémonie
nationaliste invraisemblable on a
d'ailleurs vu que maintenant il n'était
plus question de nazis plus question
d'aide humanitaire au peuple ukrainien
qui s'agissait simplement de
reconstituer la Grande Russie c'était
une cérémonie entièrement nationaliste
donc c'est évidemment non c'est un
discours très virulent contre l'Occident
pardon aussi qu'il a fait vendredi ça
comment il faut l'interpréter mais
écoutez je crois que c'est très
compliqué d'interpréter le discours de
Vladimir Poutine cette assurément un
discours très violent très très dur avec
la rhétorique habituelle de Poutine
vous savez c'est comme les ce que disent
les enfants c'est celui qui dit qu'il
est
c'est à dire qu'il accuse l'Occident de
tout ce qu'il devrait selon qu'il
devrait s'accuser lui-même
l'agressivité la volonté détruire le fin
du fin c'est c'est la cupidité la
prédation quand on voit la fortune qui
l'a constitué à la personnelle à la tête
de la Russie on se dit quand il dénonce
la cupidité nous avons affaire un
spécialiste bon donc tout ça est une
sorte de construction en miroir de
lui-même c'est extrêmement traditionnel
l'agresseur se pose tant en victime mais
derrière ça il me que l'essentiel de la
manifestation de Moscou était tournée
vers le peuple russe en lui disant voilà
nous avons les premiers avantages de ce
qui n'est pas une guerre mais ce qui est
quasiment une guerre avec les quatre les
quatre régions qui sont attachées donc
nos enfants ne sont pas morts pour rien
et du coup ça peut être pour lui la base
d'une d'un accord d'un entrée en
négociation en disant on va maintenant
je garde la Crimée je prends les quatre
LPI et on peut causer évidemment cette
proposition est inacceptable par
l'Ukraine mais international ça c'est le
problème c'est que l'idée de Poutine est
sans doute de diviser la communauté
internationale de dire un certain nombre
de pays où plus fragile comme le nôtre
d'ailleurs avec des gens qui sont assez
proûtiniens dans une partie de la
population de dire voilà il faut arrêter
les frais on va partager l'Ukraine etc
et le fait fragile dans cette histoire
on a quand même
un parti le rassemblement national qui a
été directement branché sur monsieur
Poutine et le LFI également même si au
sein de les filles on voit bien que les
éléments sont partagés mais le l'idée
notamment de ne pas aider ce qui est la
pire des hypocrisies de ne pas aider les
Ukrainiens on est solidaire des
Ukrainiens mais on leur envoie pas de
d'armes militaire
on d'accord vous on vous on vous aime
mais on vous laisse on vous laisse
crever la bouche ouverte bon ça ça va
pas vous estimez que du côté de Marine
Le Pen comme de Jean-Luc Mélenchon les
choses ne sont pas claires aujourd'hui
elles regardent donc je crois qu'elles
n'ont jamais été clair ni Hugo
mais non il n'y a pas eu le quartier
toute l'idée que développe par exemple
le RN c'est dire il faut pas faire de
sanction
c'est c'est ça maintenant les sanctions
pédales or il est absolument clair que
les sanctions les sanctions sur le sur
le le gaz et sur le pétrole non pas bien
fonctionné en termes de prix
au bout des sanctions on est
certainement pas arrivé au bout des
sanctions mais les Russes sont
certainement arriver assez loin dans la
privation on dit qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
ils en sont à détacher les les les puces
et les existants sur les sur le matériel
les arts ménagers pour les affecter à
des à à des équipements militaires il y
a donc une une extrême essoufflement de
l'économie russe la technologie russe
qui est la conséquence de de des
sanctions
par intérim du rassemblement national il
dit les sanctions sont les
semi-conducteurs ça marche les sanctions
contre les oligarques ça marche mais les
sanctions sur l'énergie sur le gaz
notamment ce sont les Français qui en
payent les conseils
il faut se méfier de ce que de commenter
les choses qu'on n'a pas vraiment lu
même si je suis tout à fait confiant
dans la sincérité et la véracité de
votre interprétation mais je crois qu'en
tout cas ce serait une évolution parce
que moi ce que j'ai entendu jusqu'à
présent de la part de Madame Le Pen et
c'était une condamnation nette et sans
bavure des sanctions il faut d'autres
sanctions sur l'énergie donc il faut
continuer il faut certainement
je vais vous dire l'essentiel selon moi
c'est effectivement de continuer à fixer
la haute technologie russe et c'est
surtout de de d'alimenter l'Ukraine en
armement en munition en moyen de frapper
à long terme l'Ukraine a bénéficié
l'Ukraine a réussi pour trois raisons la
première c'est la détermination morale
et la bonne organisation très
décentralisée d'ailleurs de ces troupes
ça on a vu on a vu ça les vraiment le
système c'est un qui fonctionne à la
base deuxièmement un armement continu
qui avec des armes très bonnes le César
français les grands canaux américains à
très longues distances etc et il faut
assurer la continuité le
rat du visage allemand en munitions et
troisièmement une innovation stratégique
de première grandeur qui est ce que les
militaires appellent la transparence de
la transparence du champ de bataille
c'est-à-dire que les Russes peuvent pas
faire un mètre un mouvement d'un mètre
sans que les systèmes d'information
occidentaux les repères sache où ils
sont les informations sont communiquées
à qui de droit et les riposes sont donc
à la fois
sur ses livraisons d'arbres qu'est-ce
qui vous dit vous dit c'est suffisant
on n'est pas rentré dans une négociation
c'est plus loin il nous a parlé
il a pas du tout marqué l'idée qu'on en
faisait pas assez etc on a du mal parce
qu'on a du mal parce que notre armée a
été très sacrifiée il y a que depuis 5
ans ça il faut rendre hommage à un
président Macron sur ce plan c'est que
la loi de programmation militaire a été
respectée dans ces objectifs ces
nouveaux le général De Villiers a quitté
le l'état majeur dans les conditions que
l'on sait mais sont testament a été si
je puis dire assumé par le Président de
la République mais il faut continuer
d'autre part nous sommes constamment
exposés sur d'autres théâtres nous avons
été au cours des 30 dernières années
exposées en Yougoslavie exposé en
Afghanistan exposé en Afrique pour en
revenir à Vladimir Poutine
la question du nucléaire il prend dit la
menace
vendredi c'était ce que je elle est
toujours elle était implicite bien sûr
il faut la prendre au sérieux
écoutez je crois que c'est une affaire
compliquée ça je pense d'abord que les
Russes ont moyen de faire de d'immense
destructions dans notre vie quotidienne
ce qui se passe en Baltique est un
avant-goût de ce qu'ils peuvent faire
sans utiliser l'arme nucléaire
deuxièmement l'arme nucléaire ça sert
absolument à rien pour eux ça
provoquerait un effet de sidération
massif c'est quelque chose qui les
mettrait complètement aux bandes des
nations de notamment des nations de
sabarquant si je puis dire la Chine là
le Brésil l'Afrique etc et donc pour
pour la Russie ce serait une calamité
donc c'est pas dit ça c'est totalement
irrationnel maintenant est-ce que
Poutine est un individu rationnel est-ce
que les hommes politiques qui sont
parvenus à ce degré de Hanoi et à ce
degré de concentration de pouvoir sont
toujours rationnels on a des exemples
historiques qui montrent que 6 Poutine
était totalement acculées par exemple
si si la con
ukrainiennes
aller réussir totalement ce qui est loin
d'être le cas parce que l'équipe des
forces n'est pas aussi aussi atteint
qu'on le dit ici ou là
une réaction de désespoir mais je crois
que la solution c'est pour ça qu'on va
s'empêcher de de résister de défendre le
colis Ukrainiens vont pas défendre leur
territoire la solution là c'est inscrit
à tout à fait raison la solution c'est
que les Russes changent de de dirigeants
c'est arrivé un an après Cuba les Russes
ce sont les Soviétiques ce sont
débarrassés kruchev c'est ça ça existe
les changements de
les modalités de l'alternance dans un
pays comme la Russie sont assez
compliqués à imaginer mais enfin là il y
a un problème et moi je trouve que le
discours de Monsieur Poutine
paradoxalement
que tout le monde a ressenti moi aussi
comme un discours extrêmement violent
contre l'Occident était un discours qui
n'était pas dénué d'une certaine volonté
de solutions rationnelle assez à
vous avez senti une ouverture
non
l'idée qu'on va quand même prendre la
moitié de le car ou le du territoire
ukrainien on peut pas construire que
c'est une ouverture mais j'ai je pense
qu'il a essayé qu'il essaie de trouver
une une voix pour se sortir lui-même de
l'impasse dans laquelle il s'est mise
donc je crois que c'était plutôt un
discours qui était comment ça peut être
quoi cette voix c'est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est de dire voilà on
arrête les frais on garde les quatre
provinces on garde la Crimée et vous
encaissez ça et si vous n'en connaissez
pas ça vous aurez froid est-ce la
solution aussi elle ne peut pas venir de
la Chine est-ce que à l'heure actuelle
ce ne sont pas les Chinois qui
détiennent éventuellement la clé de la
fente c'est la même idée c'est la même
idée c'est il a évidemment il a très
bien compris je pense l'avertissement de
sa marquant et de il a très bien compris
que les Chinois trouvaient que ça
commençait à bien faire que les Indiens
également ils ont beau trouver un peu
davantage dans les commerces
énergétiques que les Africains les
Africains avaient que ça s'arrête aussi
et donc s'il veut et les Turcs s'il veut
puisque c'est un débat entre l'Ouest
l'est et le reste et l'arbitrage du
reste est en train d'échapper pendant
longtemps l'arbitrage du reste a été
plutôt contre l'Ouest puis avec les
développements des derniers mois et
notamment les offensives réussis des
Ukrainiens l'arbitrage du reste est
plutôt contre Poutine et ça il en est
très très inquiet je reviens sur ce que
vous disiez sur les armes parce que
c'est intéressant ce que vous me disiez
disais tout à l'heure sur les armes et
sur la livraison les livraisons d'armes
qu'on fait à l'Ukraine vous rappeliez
que la France est aussi engagée sur
d'autres terrains de guerre ça veut dire
que jusqu'à quand l'armée française
pourra continuer à livrer des armes à
l'Ukraine est-ce que ça met l'armée en
péril ça m'est pas là vous savez les
problèmes les problèmes des militaires
c'est que ils ont des armements ils
aiment bien les garder pour pouvoir s'en
servir plus tard il y a toujours un
moment il faut s'en servir c'est quand
même le grand conflit que nous avons
simplement il nous abordons un débat
budgétaire dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles comme vous le
savez et là moi je suis de ceux qui
disent qu'il ne faut pas me lire sur les
dépenses militaires il ne faut pas me
lire sur l'exigence de de renforcement
de nos moyens le budget est un budget
d'augmentation des forces armées et je
crois qu'il faut soutenir cette
augmentation c'est pourquoi par ailleurs
je trouve qu'il faut faire des réformes
structurelles même s'il faut les faire
selon des modalités
acceptables comme par exemple les
réformes sur l'agir retraite je crois
que nous avons on va venir mais ça veut
dire qu'on a encore les
[Musique]
le gouvernement a demandé ce débat nous
sommes extrêmement prêts moi j'y
participerai en tant que président de ma
commission mais j'attends effectivement
et j'attends que le gouvernement marque
une détermination sans faille aux côtés
de l'Ukraine sa volonté de maintenir les
aides en armement et sa volonté de
préciser
la nature et le volume des sanctions
puisque le président a appelé un nouveau
tournevis en matière de sanction je
crois qu'il faut effectivement faire le
point sur l'efficacité des sanctions et
sur les orientations que doivent prendre
ces sanctions à l'avenir donc il faut
rester fidèle à nos engagements
maintenir notre détermination et
préciser techniquement la nature de nos
interventions dans les semaines qui
vient du rassemblement national et de la
France insoumise vous attendez aussi des
choses c'est leur affaire moi il est
rare que je sois d'accord avec eux mais
je les écoute toujours alors on va
parler d'un autre sujet on va parler de
la question de la réforme des retraites
justement puisque vais vous en parler
oui François Bayrou votre ami a donné un
coup de frein au bulldozer Emmanuel
Macron il y a quelques jours l'invitant
à prendre le temps de la discussion de
la réformer les retraites en France
est-ce qu'il est allé trop loin
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un danger que
rien se fasse oui il y a toujours un
danger que rien ne se fasse puisque rien
ne se fait en matière des retraites
depuis 5 ans et que tout économiste
sérieux est tout budgétaire sérieux
c'est que c'est la variable essentielle
sur lequel nous pouvons effectivement
agir au service de l'économie et au
service de des comptes publics français
donc il faut faire les la réforme des
retraites je ne crois pas que que
François Bayrou
proposer de différer sur le long terme
cette réforme ce qu'il a dit et je crois
que c'est très partagé la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui est de la
formation principale de la majorité qui
n'est pas au modèle à dit la même chose
au prêtre à la première ministre d'avoir
soutenu des idées comparables auprès du
président de la République
on dit le fait de passer par amendement
dans le cas de la loi PLFSS par ça ça ne
ça ne le fait pas comme disait enfants
ça ne marche pas Emmanuel
je suis
mais je mesure les mensité des forces
styles je suis et ça ça m'inquiète
beaucoup pour le pays quand on voit il y
a Monsieur Martinez mais il y a Monsieur
berger qui vient encore de la CFDT qui
vient encore de prendre des positions
très rigoureuses contre une
[Musique]
s'est arrêté sur ce sujet il y a ceux
qui veulent réformer et qui disent qu'il
faut absolument avoir une mesure de
report de l'âge légal de départ sinon ça
ne sera pas une réforme suffisamment
courageuse et les syndicats qui disent
nous on n'en veut pas bon est-ce que
cette concertation de trois mois ça va
vraiment changer quelque chose qu'on met
dedans et il faut c'est une question
centrale la question que vous posez je
n'ai pas la réponse mais je vais vous
parler très franchement j'ai été très
inquiet tout au long de la campagne
électorale que ce soit la campagne
présidentielle ou la campagne
législative je n'ai pas senti nulle part
ni dans la majorité ni dans l'opposition
des projets qui étaient adaptés à la
réalité à long terme de la situation la
campagne qu'on a faite a été tournée sur
les trois mois
fait campagne sur un allongement de la
durée de travail et qu'il estime avoir
été élu sur ce projet et qu'il a de
possibilité de réformer sur ce projet je
crois qu'il faut c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je l'ai soutenu sans
aucune arrière-pensée j'avais bien
d'autres raisons de le soutenir parce
que les options fondamentales qui sont
les siennes ce sont les mêmes que les
miennes mais sur ce point précis il a il
a pris un engagement qui a un petit peu
varié dans ces modalités en cours de
campagne et je crois qu'il faut s'y
tenir non mais ce que vous nous dites si
je comprends bien Jean-Luc mélench c'est
que personne y compris Emmanuel Macron
n'a fait campagne sur une vision long
terme sur un cap pour la France je vous
dis la même la même chose que que ce que
je dis sur l'Ukraine je trouve que dans
ces profondeurs l'opinion France thèse
n'est pas adaptée n'a pas pris
pleinement conscience des enjeux
géopolitiques économiques et sociaux
dans lequel est plongé la France et elle
n'a pas pris pleinement conscience de ce
que ça implique dans les dix années qui
viennent les politiques en ont pris
pleinement conscience est-ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron on a pris pleinement c'est très
frappant ça le Emmanuel Macron a
certainement pris conscience de cela
d'où cette impression que nous avons
tous un un peu étrange c'est à dire que
on le sent on le sent inquiet on le sent
inquiet par le décalage entre ce qu'il
sent nécessaire et qu'il dit quand il
donne des faits des propos à ces
généraux mais des propos de de réalisme
de d'appel à l'effort etc et des
réticences du pays je crois que nous
vivons ce moment particulier qui est un
moment grave parce que si nous échons si
effectivement les Français disent tous
ces efforts il nous il nous cassent les
pieds Macron nous casse les pieds les
hommes politiques les femmes politiques
nous cassent les pieds ça finira par
l'arrivée au pouvoir non pas d'ailleurs
selon moi de l'extrême gauche je pense
que les filles jouent le rôle de comme
on dit d'idiot utile dans cette affaire
c'est-à-dire qu'ils font l'agitation
mais ça risque de finir par un pouvoir
d'extrême droite qui personnellement
préoccupe beaucoup donc ça veut dire que
Marine Le Pen pourrait succéder Emmanuel
Macron pour vous si Emmanuel Macron
c'est ce qui peut se passer
c'est aussi une inquiétude que partage
François Bayrou
nous avons le et c'est apparemment ce
que partage aussi le président de la
République puisqu'on dit partout que il
voudrait pas se retrouver dans la
situation d'un Obama qui se verrait
remplacer par un homme et un scénario à
l'italienne un scénario oui enfin c'est
un on a quand même un pouvoir très à
droite en au Royaume-Uni de depuis
Johnson on a un pouvoir très à droite
maintenant en Italie on a un pouvoir
très à droite en Pologne on a un pouvoir
très à droite en Hongrie on a un pouvoir
assez à droite en Autriche tout ça et
montre que il y a une vraie dérive vers
la droite de la droite à laquelle nous
devons
faire attention parce que ça ne
correspond pas aux options ni à nos
valeurs ni à fondamental des peuples
européens qui doivent s'unir s'ils
veulent gagner dernière question très
rapidement
le gouvernement n'exclut pas de revenir
sur le non-cumul des mandats encore
quelqu'un vous en pensez quoi je pense
que on peut pas des réformes on fait pas
des réformes par petits bouts comme ça
le cumul des mandats ou non cumul des
mains ça dépend l'idée qu'on se fait du
Parlement c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
Parlement est faible et les les
parlementaires n'ont pas accès aux
responsabilités locales donc les
parlementaires c'est un peu le couteau
sans l'âme au qualiment que le manche en
mettant bon mais moi je suis plutôt
partisan de renforcer le pouvoir du
Parlement donc de faire la
proportionnelle pour que le pouvoir du
Parlement soit véritablement différent
organisé différemment du pouvoir
présidentiel et qui puisse peser
pleinement sur le retour d'un députés
mères ou sénateurs
de députés de mer et laisser un commerce
et le retour de du président roi